sticker shock as they begin their  back-to-school shopping  price jumps are being blamed on  coronavirus shutdowns and their impact  on supply chains retailers are still  trying to get back to normal  as shipping prices go up those  costs um in terms of actually  transporting goods that  that has been a major concern for many  of the retailers we've talked to  all right and the national retail  federation estimates  listen to this we'll spend 37.1  billion dollars on on back to school  supplies this year as things have  reopened  that's up more than three billion  dollars from last year  and a reminder our annual great school  supply drive runs through next thursday  we're collecting a whole bunch of things  like backpacks pencils  wipes other supplies to help out people  people in our community  you can drop off donations at any smith  stores around the valley now through  july the 29th